Okay. Everyone first, thank you for
coming out on such a blustery day.
If you've not picked up your exam
from your teaching fellow, uh,
you can do that after class today.
And we're switching gears.
We're moving from a questions about how
to manage chemicals in the environment
to questions about how to affect
conservation and also especially how to
allocate and manage land use,
uh,
and various natural resources
associated with landscapes.
And today I'm gonna use an example,
uh,
a history of a conservation
effort in New York state, uh,
known as the Adirondack Park
that has a conservation, uh, uh,
history that now spans almost 130 years,
one of the oldest parks in the nation.
And it contains many terrific examples
of a variety of different strategies to
conserve resources and
to protect the land. Now,
no matter where you are in the world,
then if you're interested
in managing land use, uh,
and managing ecosystems
or biological resources,
there a variety of questions that
I'd encourage you ask. You know,
one is first to become
familiar with property rights.
How are they defined? Who has
rights to which types of resources?
And in this case,
it'll become clear that it's important
for you to think about property not as a
thing. Uh, but as a set
of social relationships,
a property is often defined in law
as a bundle, a bundle of rights. Uh,
but if I have a right that's
defined and protected by law, uh,
than others have an obligation.
So you can't really think about rights
in the absence of consideration of
obligations.
And if you violate your obligation,
the concept behind a property right
is that the state or some level of
government will have
the capacity to monitor,
to discover the defect,
uh, to enforce sanctions.
Uh, so the second question that, uh,
you need to consider is what
is the appropriate level
of government to institute
protective policy? Uh, should local
governments have this ability?
Often they don't because they have
other obligations and their financial
background is,
is quite slight in comparison to state
governments or the federal government.
So thinking about the particular
nature of a problem, you know,
whether it crosses especially
political boundaries,
so many watersheds is an example.
Cross political boundaries
across town boundaries.
They call it cross state boundaries.
Uh, many water bodies, uh, uh,
provide the boundary between political
jurisdictions as well as nation states.
So thinking about the appropriate level
of government to the kind of problem
you're interested in managing
is a really important task.
How about participation
in decision making?
As you think about
conservation strategies,
what should be the role of the public
in participating in the type of strategy
that chosen? And you might think of, you
might think of a track of land that, uh,
everybody feels is very special.
Uh,
perhaps because it has
endangered species per cap,
perhaps because of its open space
character, perhaps its wildness,
uh, you might think of a
variety of different strategies
to protect that if it's
currently in private ownership.
And one of those would be land acquisition
by on the part of the government.
So many national parks, for example,
particularly in the eastern United States,
had been created through the
process of land acquisition.
And in some instances the
exercise of eminent domain.
And we'll talk about eminent domain where
the government uses its authority to a
cry, acquire a property
for public purposes. Uh,
virtually by taking it away from,
uh, the private owner. Uh, but,
but providing compensation
intensity regulation
regulation is another strategy.
So you might simply adopt rules
that govern density of allowable new
development, uh, or the type of new
development, whether it's residential,
commercial, agricultural, industrial, uh,
and this is the origin of the idea
of zoning land use, segregation,
a land use, density control, and often
associated subdivision regulations,
which are very specific in detail,
how development has to
proceed including lots sizes,
a shoreline access requirements,
a variety of different restrictions are
associated with subdivision regulations.
How about the legitimacy of public value?
If you create a really tough set of
land use regulations and the property
owners, uh, do not believe in
the legitimacy of the regulation,
it guarantees that you're
going to have compliance.
And noncompliance means that you're
going to have extensive surveillance and
monitoring costs and enforcement costs.
So believing in the legitimacy
of the public value is important.
Often an educational process has to take
place in order for people to understand
why regulations are occurring.
And in many cases,
they're developed and
adopted to prevent damage.
The damage that might be induced by
one property owner on an adjacent,
an adjacent public, a private
owner. So the idea of uh, uh,
deciding that you want to build
a casino on your property,
your neighbors might object to
that or perhaps a, a, a nightclub,
a so that there are variety of
different land uses that, that uh,
threaten other land
owners in the vicinity.
Property value often rises
following a conservation efforts.
So the establishment of a park is, is
very commonly followed by adjacent land.
Value's increasing quite dramatically.
And I'll provide you with a couple of
examples of that. Density restrictions,
land use, segregation, aesthetics.
Increasingly over the past half century
we've seen zoning ordinances being used
for the purpose of controlling aesthetics.
So aesthetics might be
managed by specifying density
guidelines requiring larger
and larger low lot sizes. So in parts of
the California coastal area, for example,
there are zoning ordinances that demand
a hundred acres before a new housemate
constructed a, this is to preserve
the open space character of the area.
So thinking about how you
define a desirable a or an
ideal aesthetic that would
be your objective is a
pretty difficult thing to do.
The forest service started pioneering
research into, to the question of,
of what, uh, types of
landscapes to people prefer.
And they were doing this because they
were getting increasingly, uh, uh,
taken to court because of the perceived
aesthetic damage associated with
clearcuts, particularly clear
cuts that were visible, uh,
because of timber leases they'd allocated,
but they would be visible from
a nearby wilderness areas.
So they decided that they would
establish a, a variety of,
of social experiments where they would
test people's preferences for different
kinds of landscapes ranging from the wild
to the fully domesticated agricultural
to a intense urban centers.
Uh,
you might be interested in the
results and following new regulation.
When does the government have the
obligation to compensate? So supposing a,
I'm a private landowner and I have 50
acres of land and you develop a new zoning
ordinance that tells me that I have to
have a 25 acres before I can build a new
house. So that tells me I basically
have two building lots. Well,
I thought that I would have a,
prior to that regulation,
perhaps 50 building lots that
might be one acre in size.
So my expectation has been suddenly
changed by the passage of law,
uh, and my property value
would significantly diminish.
So under what situations,
uh,
does the government need to compensate
the private landowner for regulatory
activity? Not, I'd like to drop you
down onto the case of the Adirondacks.
But first I'd like you to think about
the distribution of public land in the
United States.
So out of several hundred million acres
of land that are currently under the
jurisdiction of the National Park
Service or the forest service,
or the bureau of land management
or the bureau of reclamation,
the majority of these lands are
located in the western United States,
particularly in the
mountain narrowed region.
If you look in the eastern
part of the United States,
you can't see this too clearly because
of the light that's on up here.
I don't know if it's possible
to diminish that at all.
But as you move toward a
northern New England, uh,
you might be able to make out a patch
of landscape right up in this area.
And that's the Adirondack park.
It's one of the largest intact forests
that we've got in the eastern United
States, actually one of the largest
intact forest that we've got, uh, uh,
in the lower 48 states.
And it also is adjacent to Vermont,
which is adjacent to New Hampshire and
Maine. And, and together these are,
are clustered and form what is now
thought of as the northern forests in the
eastern eastern part of the
country. And the Adirondacks, uh,
within this zone has the longest history
of protection, but there are the green,
there are the green mountains, and there's
the green mountain national forest,
and there are the white mountains
in adjacent New Hampshire, uh,
that spill over into, into Maine.
So there's really quite a, uh,
an unusual track of land, uh, that,
uh, uh, has a, a long and, and,
uh, curious conservation
history. Again, a, a,
a bit of a closer look at the Adirondacks.
As you look out across this landscape.
Uh,
you might think of it as wild
and natural, uh, but in reality,
it's the location of intense conflicts
over a competing interest groups about
how they might best gain
access to public lands. Uh,
this is the Adirondack forest preserve,
a protected since the 1880s.
Uh, if you look back at the history
of conservation effort in the nation,
like Yosemite was deeded to
California and 1864, Yellowstone,
Yellowstone national park was created in
1872 and the Adirondack forest reserve
was created in 1885. It was transformed
into a park a few years later. Um,
and an and a 1895,
uh,
the New York state legislature passed a
constitutional amendment so that a lands
that are designated as
forest reserve lands and now
called forest preserve lands,
they are forever protected by the
Constitution of New York state. So that,
that means that two successive,
uh, legislatures need to, to, uh,
enact a statute that would allow them
to be transferred out of that category.
So this is a very rigorous standard that
is, is, is hard to change. And by the way,
there are different kinds of laws that
might be applied such as the executive
order on, uh, by, uh, William
Clinton that the creative,
the largest, uh, track of, of,
uh, wilderness, uh, by,
by relying on, uh, uh,
federally owned,
uh,
but non wilderness lands up in
Alaska just before he left office.
So you could use a federal executive
order to accomplish wilderness designation
or the, the, uh, forest service or,
or the park service or the
bureau of land management.
They could also administratively designate
tracks of land as being wilderness
that, uh, under or under
their jurisdiction.
So that in terms of the gold standard
of offering the greatest amount of
protection,
uh,
you would want a designation that would
be very difficult to change in New York
state. And the legislature, I
think, got it right back in the,
and the 1890s when they created
the forest and jumping ahead, uh,
the wilderness statute in the United
States wasn't adopted until 1864.
And then, uh, in 18th, or
excuse me, in 1968, uh,
the Adirondack national park was proposed
by a variety of individuals in New
York state.
And this upset people in the Adirondacks
quite a bit because they were worried
about losing control.
There were a Lulu or
concerned about losing their
authority and their ability to
affect a policy within their,
within their park, within the,
within the state. Uh, and
this prompted, uh, uh,
the legislature to move ahead by 1971
and create the Adirondack park agency.
Excuse me.
Okay.
Then by 18 or 1973,
the Adirondack park agency land use
planning and regulation went into effect.
And this really will be the
topic of the discussion today.
Thinking about the forces
that a lay behind the, uh,
the development of the statute
might, uh, consider the Erie Canal.
A Uri canal runs from the
eastern side of New York, uh,
all the way to the western edge. And, uh,
when the timber resources in the
park, uh, were poorly managed, uh,
when they, the tops of trees were
left on the, on the ground, uh,
and they dry it out, they would
burn in forest fires. And the,
in the 1860s, seventies, and eighties,
we're really common response to these,
uh, mismanaged a forest plans,
uh, drying out. So what happens,
what a track of forest, uh, uh, Burns,
it basically loses its flood
storage capacity. Uh, doesn't, uh,
the organic matter in the
soil often is, is uh, uh,
released,
it breaks down so that water running
off the landscape commonly floods.
So you get a burst into the rivers and
through the Erie Canal and then you get
drought. So that, uh, if, if,
uh, New York state w was, uh,
going to ensure that commerce
could move westward, uh,
it had to ensure a more sustainable
form of forest management in the park.
I also think about what was happening
in the middle of the 19th century. Uh,
there were several movements
in literature and, and art, uh,
and also in a college either are quite
curious and they were colliding in a way
that a really provided a impetus for the
creation of parks and protected areas.
And one strain of thought, uh,
known as transcendentalism, uh,
that you can discover in the writings
of Samuel Taylor Coleridge and Shelley
Keats, uh, William Wordsworth,
Emerson, Whitman and throw a,
and particularly Emerson's
essay on nature, uh,
cause people to think very differently
about nature and what it was and its
importance to the human condition.
Uh, so that s a a r excuse me,
that a nature to, to Emerson, uh, uh,
was an organism is a symbol of the mind.
It was a moral educator,
a source of spiritual truth and
a resource for the imagination.
Now, at the same time, George
Perkins Marsh was writing, uh,
and he produced a book
called men in nature, talking
about the destruction that,
uh, uh, the destruction of forests and
how that might lead to the decline of
civilizations. Quite curious.
Uh, the writings in the,
in the latter part of the 19th century.
The Pre saged, uh, the, the, uh,
loss of diversity, uh, as
well as climate change, uh,
that we're now experiencing.
So he wrote back in 1864 a
condition of impoverished,
impoverished productiveness
of shattered surface, uh,
of climatic access has to
threaten deprivation, barbarism,
and even even extinction of species.
So nearly a century and a half ago,
uh, a scientist, uh,
was predicting climate change associated
the way with the way that we were
mismanaging resources and
landscape. Also, the targets,
the transcendentalists include Christian
views are they challenged the human
role, uh, to be one of
dominating nature, uh, the,
the Christian view that we should be
fruitful and multiply and replenish the
earth and subdue it. Uh,
and that Christianity denies
souls to nonhuman species.
These were new and very interesting
thoughts to people. This is captured in a,
in a,
a work produced by Roderick Nash
Wilderness in the American mind that's
published by Yale Press,
uh,
that I commend to you if you're interested
in and following the way that these,
uh, ideas collided. Now at the same time,
there were many artists that
were painting landscapes,
both in the western part of the
nation as well as in the east,
including Thomas Cole and Albert Beers
tot a Winslow homer in Frederick Church,
and they all painted in the Adirondacks.
So think about the fact that, uh,
people were reading the transcendentalists
literature at the same time that,
uh, these art shows we're traveling
around, not just the United States,
but traveling around the world, giving
people a very different impression of,
of what it was like in the more
remote parts of the United States.
So a Winslow homer has painted more
on the Adirondacks and the others.
So I just thought I'd show you
his work on two guides, uh,
the hunter, uh, and the fishermen, uh,
basically celebrating the
experience of being in the outdoors.
I'm going to fast forward on Youtube,
the, the middle part of the 19th,
or excuse me, the 20th century.
Uh, when you recall that,
I argued that the interstate highway
system was built, uh, you know,
largely in response to concerns about
the Cold War. Uh, but this network, uh,
eventually ringed the Adirondack park
and it made it accessible by the early
1960s to more than 10 million million,
excuse me,
million people within a day's drive.
So access is really a critical
determinant of property value.
And also the rate of development
by the 1960s in the 60s,
in 1970s, uh, increasing,
uh, uh, leisurely time, increasing
demand for recreational opportunities,
I'll lead to increasing property
values within the Adirondacks.
People were looking for second homes.
Uh, the development industry was booming,
not just here, but also, uh,
in the vicinity of Bar Harbor in
Maine and the vicinity of, uh,
of Grand Teton and, and, uh, uh,
Jackson, Wyoming, uh, also in, in, uh,
uh, the Sierras so that, uh,
the population in the United
States wanted access to,
to a remote recreational opportunities.
There was a real interest in, in wildness,
in nature, uh, particularly, uh,
in a, in the concept of wilderness.
And quite, uh, quite honestly, I'm
surprised that your generation,
I don't see the same interest in wildness
or wilderness that, uh, was, was, uh,
very, uh, very prominent in people's
concerns about conservation. Uh,
back in the 1970s so that, uh, uh,
many inlet than the
legislature in New York, uh,
became concerned about development
being financed, uh, with, uh,
international capital in the park,
rapid cutting of the forest,
rapid development,
particularly along shorelines and
rapid increases in property value
in some communities, uh, communities that
had populations of only 300 people, uh,
new new projects were proposed,
uh,
up to 10,000 new units
in size. Uh, if you, uh,
then extrapolate that a one new housing
unit might house on average two to three
people, uh, this, uh,
could multiply the population of a
community by 10 or, or even a 20 times.
So what would that mean
for that community?
What would it mean in terms of it's a
need to invest in institutional support
for the community. And by that, what do I
mean? Well, how about a road development,
highway development, school
systems, fire, police,
so that the economic per pressure was
being brought to bear on these communities
there already where the most
impoverished in New York state,
that band of forest that I pointed out
to you in northern New England is a
demographically quite interesting.
It's,
it's grown to be bi modal in terms of
income distribution in a dominated more
heavily by the poorest.
Uh,
but also there are increasing numbers of
private property owners who own second
homes, but they don't
vote. They don't vote, uh,
in the Adirondacks and many of them don't
vote in New York state. Uh, so that,
that uh, this, this by
Moodle distribution, uh,
creates a very interesting
political dynamic, uh,
attention between those that
have always lived there,
that are poor as opposed to those that
have the capacity to buy the new houses,
uh, and bring their conservation
values, uh, to the Adirondacks.
So this statute was really
unusual. And, uh, the,
the preamble to the statute
includes this language.
Local governments in the Adirondack park
find it increasingly difficult to cope
with the unrelenting pressures
for development being
brought to bear on the area
and to exercise their discretionary
powers to create an effective land use and
development control framework.
Now,
the mission statement of this
law is really quite complex.
The basic purpose of this article is
to ensure optimum overall conservation
protection, preservation, development,
and use of the sea unique scenic,
aesthetic, wildlife,
recreational, open space,
historic ecological and natural
resources of the Adirondack Park.
So within mission statement,
you should, uh, you know,
immediately see a number
of potential conflicts.
How can you at once maximize conservation
at the same time you're maximizing
development in use.
Actually,
it's interesting if you drive into a
national forest to see a sign beside the,
the, uh, the edge of the road when you
enter all national forest and that, uh,
the sign will say, land of many
uses a land of many uses. Well,
how do you reconcile multiple
uses within one track of, of, uh,
uh, land managed by a public agency? Well,
it's difficult at best and that's
largely part of the story today.
Innovative requirements in this statute,
a domain at an ecological analysis.
So what is the resiliency of
different ecological zones,
a different ecosystems, uh, how much
development can they sustain? Uh,
and is there a logic behind
a allocating a density,
a requirement to a different
types of ecosystems?
How about density regulations
and the clustering concept? Uh,
this statute relied on the idea that you
should concentrate new development, uh,
in close proximity to village centers
so that you don't overstress, uh,
the local governments need to develop
new roads to maintain those roads, uh,
and also require new power lines,
new sewage lines, new water lines.
So the idea that a cluster development
build on existing, uh, uh, centers of,
of the population is
really quite interesting.
And this was to protect the open space
character as well as the ecological
characteristics, uh, of the
surrounding landscape. It wasn't,
it wasn't devo designed really
to a, uh, conserve energy. Uh,
but if I were going to
challenge you to design a today,
a land use regulatory scheme,
that would be the most
conserving of energy resources,
it probably would follow this model and
it would follow the model because if you
have people living closer
together, uh, uh, you,
you were clearly not going to use
as much fuel moving around, uh,
uh, between shopping and recreation
and school and other, other activities.
So if you increase the density or excuse
me, increase the density restriction,
you, you, uh, increase the, uh,
amount of land area required before a
new house might be developed between the
village centers, uh, then that would
discourage development in those areas.
And in the case of the park,
uh, in the, inside the centers,
there's no density restriction at all.
So it's an encouragement basically to
build up, uh, between the village centers.
Uh,
in the more remote areas,
there's a requirement that you have 42
acres before a new house can be built.
42 acres is a lot of land.
42 acres. In Connecticut,
most Connecticut is zoned on
average one acre per new unit.
So 42 units might be placed on that does,
um,
but only one could be placed on that area.
Within the Adirondacks.
It also required setback requirements,
set back requirements, uh,
from especially water bodies,
uh, streams and lakeshores. Uh,
and this,
uh,
wild to urban continuum continuum was
designed really with an aesthetic purpose
to try to protect the park,
like character of the area. Uh,
it also had a provision that was
really new back in the 1970s, uh,
to offer specific protection
for agricultural lands. Uh,
so that agricultural
lands were thought of, uh,
not the way that we would think of them
today is providing an opportunity for a
locally grown produce that
would be more energy efficient,
but they were designed predominantly to
protect the open space character of the
park vista preservation.
So that individual vistas were
identified actually. Yeah. That,
that's kind of an interesting sidelight
story about how that occurred. You know,
one might think that,
uh,
when there really might not be a legally
defensible means of going out and
identifying what the most beautiful
areas are, uh, in an area this large.
Uh, so the Adirondacks is a, is a
roughly 6 million acres in size.
It's larger than Yosemite Yellowstone
and glacier national parks put together.
Uh, so that a wandering around and
trying to figure out where the, the, uh,
the ideal vistas are located,
who was a challenge that the,
the park agency had to confront. They were
required to do that by statute. Uh, the,
uh, the reality of how
they did it, uh, is that a,
an engineer and a survey or got into
a pickup truck with a case of beer,
a and drove around for a weekend looking
for what they thought were pretty
landscapes. Uh, they put pins
in a map and a Lo and behold,
these pin holes in the map,
uh,
translated into a legally binding
regulations that prevented development of
different forms in the
vicinity of the scenic vista.
A wetlands and wild and
scenic and recreational rivers
were also designated. A,
the definition of a wetland is actually
quite interesting and quite difficult.
Uh, today is, uh, as I was
coming into, uh, uh, to give
a lecture, I noticed that, uh,
areas, uh, that normally look dry,
uh, had standing water in them. Uh,
and, uh, so that low lying areas,
uh, can be, uh, quite deceptive.
Uh, if you're, if you're not there
during extreme rain events, uh,
so that a wetland designation gave the
Adirondack Park Agency jurisdiction to
deny development people were not allowed
to build in wetlands period. Uh, now,
most states have wetlands laws as well.
Uh, not just, uh, in the Adirondacks.
Uh, most states do not have wild scenic
and recreational river statutes, uh,
that provide the a, an overlay on top
of the Adirondack Park Agency statute.
Uh, finally, uh,
the provision that a stirred terrific
controversy was that the zoning authority
that previously held was held by local
governments was overtaken by the state
government.
So not only would you have private
property owners that would be highly
resistant to this new set of very
complicated regulations that they viewed
actually took away their private property
rights and diminish their property
value. Uh, but they also, uh,
had local governments that, uh,
uh, felt that they were being pushed
out of the picture, that they,
their zoning responsibility that they'd
had for a hundred more than a hundred
years,
that that was taken away from him.
So that the statute's set
up class eight projects,
which were large development projects
that might have more of a regional
influence. And those were reviewed by
the state in class beat projects, uh,
were reviewed by local governments,
but only if the local government's adopted
the state standards to apply to those
projects. So if you were given
the responsibility to, to, uh, uh,
develop, uh, an ecologically grounded
approach to land use regulation,
what would you do?
We probably would go off and conduct an
inventory of what resources are there in
the, in the park. You look for
aquifers, uh, you'd map them out,
you'd map out surface waters and you'd
map out a setback distances from those
surface waters to try to be
sure to protect water quality.
You take a look at surficial geology,
uh,
particularly areas that had shallow
soils are soils that had Claybon.
Ethan at our annex is rather famous
for its clay. Uh, which means that a,
you have a clay impervious surface that
is often only a one or two feet beneath
the, uh, the top of landscape.
That means that if you're going to put
in a septic system and a septic system
basically means that human sewage from
a facility or a house goes down into a
pipe, it goes into a holding tank, uh,
solid settle out and then fluid drains
off and it leeches out through pipes that
have holes in the bottom of them, uh,
and then down through a bed of sand.
But if there is a clay area
that lies beneath the sand,
that means that the sewage is
going to stay close to the surface.
It's not going to dissipate,
it's not going to break down.
And it means that bacterial contamination
of a surface water supplies is much
more probable. Genital soils
characteristics were also mapped.
A elevation was mapped. And I'll tell
you more about that in just a second,
as well as land use. Where
are the residential areas? Uh,
so that the idea of clustering development
in close proximity to where existing
development, uh, was, was a critical,
uh, way of thinking about this.
Now,
our land cover also was considered to
whether or not to track of land was
forested, whether or not it was heath
land I, whether or not it was wetland. Uh,
so that the biological resources we're
also mapped on top of where did the state
lands lie? So there are 107 towns
and villages in the Adirondack Park.
So 107,
uh,
different local governments that were
upset with the state of New York for
taking their authority away, but they all
had to go through this mapping process.
Uh,
so those of you that are familiar with
geographic information systems know that
this process now goes on electronically.
So soils and vegetation and land
use and property ownership patterns,
they're, they're all piled on top
of one another electronically.
So you can zoom in or you could change
the layers that you're looking at. Uh,
instantly.
In this case,
they drew these maps out by hand
and that actually led to some pretty
interesting problems. Uh, when, uh,
private land owners would come to
the government and say, you know,
I'm not certain what zone I'm in,
I appear to be on a boundary.
And it turned out that, uh, by
drawing a line on a map, uh, that, uh,
is really small and
scale, that the, uh, the,
the width of the line itself often was
a hundred yards wide and a hundred yards
may or may not include all
the property of an individual.
So which section would they lie within
the 42 acre zone or perhaps the a 3.2
acre zone and made a huge difference in
the eventual saleability and property
value, uh, of the area. And
also proximity to roads. Uh,
I mean if you think about an area you'd
also want to know that we're the new
road network was he'd what you would
think very carefully about how you would
allocate density based upon access to,
to roadways.
So all of this information was put
together, uh, to develop, uh, this map,
which is a legal instrument. The idea
that a map might be a legal instrument.
It's kind of an interesting
thought. Uh, so that, uh,
in order for someone to know what their
rights are, their property rights are,
they would have to pinpoint
themselves on this map.
And each color is associated
with a certain density allowance.
So if you are located in the green,
that means that a,
you need 42 acres in order
to develop a new house.
If you're located in the
Yellow, oh, that's eight acres.
If you're located in the red,
then you only need one acre.
And if you're located in the village
centers, it's designated as Brown.
You have no density requirement.
It is all and at all, by the way,
you've heard about cap and trade.
Well,
the cap and trade idea can be applied
very well to a situation like this, uh,
so that you might allow trading rights
under certain circumstances, uh,
within a designated boundary, perhaps
within a community. So that a,
the idea of transferable
development rights, uh,
it's something that we'll
talk about, uh, next week.
So these are the different zoning, uh, uh,
limits that have been established
by law and have governed.
The Adirondack Park Agency
is implementation of this
plan for quite a while.
How does this play out as you're
looking at a landscape? Uh, well,
here's a little community.
It's a community of, of
King Valley, uh, that, uh,
is just at the foot of
the high peaks region,
the highest mountains in New York state.
And,
and this is a community
of about 800 people.
And here's the village center
with no density requirements.
And as you move away from the
village center, you find that a,
you're required to have
larger and larger lots, uh,
before you can build a new structure
until you reach a, the public lands, uh,
which,
uh,
begin in this case up on these hillsides
leading up into the high peaks so that
you can think about this as a kind
of a set of concentric circles.
Uh, it's much more complicated than just
concentric circles, but a development,
a ranging from the urban center on
one hand to wilderness areas that are
designated on the other hand so that
the public lands have their own set of
regulations under this statute,
the village of Lake placid where
the Olympic Games was held,
provides a good example of this where you
see the Brown and the center, uh, is, uh,
the area where there are no density
requirements. And then the lands that, uh,
a border, the federal wilderness
areas designated by this blue, uh,
they have the higher, uh,
higher restrictions, the
requirement for larger acreages.
So we're a battlegrounds. Where would
you imagine you would get the most, uh,
litigation? Where would you, uh,
find that the greatest amount of, of,
uh, private conflict, uh,
over these, these regulations?
Well, one clearly would
be, uh, areas with views,
so areas that have a high
elevations or areas that,
that are adjacent to water bodies.
So if you were going to
map out property values,
you would find that areas that had the
best views that had the highest elevation
and that were adjacent to either rivers
or lakes or ponds would have the highest
property values.
So you can be predictive about this,
about where you're going to receive
your, your greatest amount of, of, uh,
conflict and resistance to new regulation.
When property values are highest, uh,
you'll find people are most
anxious to, uh, to develop. Uh,
the rate of development occurs more
rapidly along roadways along the lakes and
rivers. And, uh, uh, the, uh,
costs of developing in the mountainous
areas at higher elevation are more
prohibitive to developers.
So shoreline such as, uh, uh,
this example on the lake
shores are, are, uh, extremely,
uh, uh, desirable from the
perspective of a developer,
a multi million dollar boat houses
that had been constructed also,
uh, hotels and, and, uh,
uh, large camps on islands.
There are more than a thousand islands
on a Adirondack lakes and ponds. Uh,
here's, uh, here's one of them
in, in Lake George as an example,
a lake George provides the water
supply for its town. Uh, so that,
uh, the, the water is, it's treated
with chlorine like new haven's water is,
it's filtered in a very
rough way through sand, uh,
but it's not filtered
by a activated carbon,
which could remove a variety of different
kinds of organic pollutants, uh,
that might be in the water supply.
Uh, so in this situation, if, if, uh,
this facility, I had a, uh,
its own a leaching field,
you'd be worried about it because most
of the islands in the Adirondacks are,
are basically mountains of bedrock that
have very shallow soils on them that
have very low capacity to absorb
a human sewage. So that a,
there is a considerable conflict
between the developers interest to build
adjacent to water bodies and the concern
of these communities to protect their,
their water supplies.
Another good example over
a prime development land
from the perspective of, of,
of, uh, the investor would be
a scenic vistas such as this.
This is one of the 40 odd scenic
vistas is that, that, uh, uh,
had specific development restrictions,
uh,
so that it sits on the,
just adjacent to mountain van Hoven Berg
and overlooks the Adirondack high peaks
and a developer,
a Mcdonald's corporation decided that
this was a site that they wanted to put a
Mcdonald's up for. Uh, when they, uh, when
we're preparing for the Olympic Games,
they didn't want to go next
to Wendy's or, uh, to, uh,
build their golden arch next
to, uh, uh, Burger King. Uh,
and there was a strip already built in
lake placid, uh, just nearby. Uh, but, uh,
their vision of, of, of what
might look best in this area.
It was something like this. Well,
the restrictions in the map,
the fact that a, the surveyor
and uh, and, uh, the, uh, uh,
other park agency employee had to
put a pin in this area, gave the,
the state of New York the authority to
deny a permit to, to this developer, uh,
simply based on aesthetic grounds.
Uh,
the developer eventually did construct
Mcdonald's next to the Wendy's and burger
kings on the strip and lake placid.
Here's another example of a
developer developer that proposed a,
a several hundred unit condominium
complex on the edge of lake placid. Uh,
Lake Placid Lake Lake George also
provides a water from the lake to its
community as their drinking water source.
And they're very sensitive
about different threats to it,
whether or not it's a motorboat, uh,
develop a motorboat, uh, use, uh,
or whether or not it's a new
development on the lake shore.
This is a very large and a beautiful
lake and the water quality is
extraordinarily high.
Uh,
so here you see that a part of
this complex is a golf course,
but they wanted to build
hundreds of additional
condominium units. And, uh, the,
the argument that a developer
will make, there's often, uh,
when I called technologically optimistic,
you know,
we can build this without causing
any a decline in water quality. Uh,
within the lake. We will have the state
of the art sewage treatment system.
We will be sure that no
sewage reaches the lake. Uh,
we will also construct our buildings,
which they wanted on the edge of the lake,
uh,
in a way that would not cause sediment to,
to a flow into the lake so that there
would be no diminished, uh, water clarity.
The water clarity issue is often a
very significant point of debate. Uh,
with respect to new
development and Lake Tahoe,
it's been extremely important because
the clarity of Lake Tahoe over those that
have you been, have been there
is, is exceptionally high. Uh,
they measure this by a Secchi
disk reading, which is a,
just a disc that they dropped down into
the water and you can see that disc in
Lake Tahoe, uh, at about 50 feet in
depth, which is really pretty remarkable.
But gradually over several decades,
uh,
the visibility declined and it was
because of development on the lake shores.
It was because of sedimentation and
also a runoff from adjacent, uh,
agricultural uses or, uh, uh,
say a runoff from streets and roads and
parking lots that were building up in,
inside the watershed so that most
communities that have lakes of,
of extremely high quality had this
concern. And it, it justifies their, uh,
adopting tougher zoning
regulations. In this case, uh,
when I worked in the Adirondacks,
I happen to be responsible for the state
of New York's review of, of the project.
And remember very distinctly, uh,
the, the initial proposal and, uh,
uh, my response, a requesting
additional information, uh, that, uh,
was about a 50 page letter that,
uh, I and, and colleagues wrote,
uh, that, uh,
we felt we needed in order to understand
the environmental impacts of this
development on the lake. Well, the
developer decided that, uh, uh,
they would scale the development back
quite substantially. They wanted a marina,
for example, uh, that would be suitable
for at least a hundred motor boats. Uh,
but the villagers and lake
placid didn't want motor boats.
Motor motors on boats are notoriously
inefficient, meaning that, uh,
much of the fuel, uh, he's
burned. But, uh, you know, uh, uh,
there is a proportion
at that point in time,
it was between 10 and 12% for the
standard engines that were being used on a
motor boats is simply shunted
into the water. So that, uh, uh,
slicks a are common around Marina's,
uh, that really are our, uh,
evidence of, of their
inefficiency. So gradually, a,
the proposal was whittled back from
several hundred units to, uh, uh,
several dozen units.
Uh,
the developer agreed not to build the
marina need agreed also to put the,
the buildings back further from the water,
uh,
to protect it from a
sedimentation, uh, and uh,
protect the water clarity and the total
amount of impervious surface allowed,
uh, uh, uh, uh, was, was also
a restricted, so the number of,
of uh, uh, parking spaces
for example, or the size of,
of,
of the track of land that they owned,
a that could actually be
covered by the pervious surface.
So these are all regulatory tools and
strategies that could be used to protect
this area. In addition, uh,
a darker color for the buildings was
required in building height was restricted
and this was to protect
the character of the area.
If you were looking at this site, uh,
from, uh, the middle of Lake placid,
looking back at mountain peaks
and looking at, at, uh, the,
the public lands that live back here.
It's a very natural looking landscape
and that was something that was, uh,
protected by the statute.
Uh, so that, uh, the,
the Adirondack Park Agency had
the authority to say, no, sorry.
You got to make sure that your
building is dark in color. Uh,
and that it's not higher than,
than x stories. So that, uh,
what's really driving, uh, the, uh, uh,
concern about this is his
underlying, uh, instincts,
underlying ideologies about a
appropriate uses of land and appropriate
definitions of private property rights,
a libertarian instinct as
opposed to an authoritarian
instinct. So the, the, uh, uh,
longtime residents to the Adirondacks,
uh,
would march down the street
with the American flag and,
and, uh, argue that, uh,
their freedom,
that their liberty was being violated
by this communist organization that has
taken away their property
rights and not compensated them.
So the centralization of authority has
been the primary mechanism of affecting
conservation policy in the United States.
Taking the private property rights or
assuming a authority to control public
lands, uh, is a form of, of a
concentration of authority. Uh,
also the ideology of a
utilitarianism that these resources,
resources are there for
human benefit in human use.
And we ought to be allowed to,
to gain access to them.
We got to be able to cut down the
timber on a forest preserve land.
We got to be able to, to
a ride our snowmobiles a
across these trails that, uh,
the preservationists instincts,
they're concerned about the noise,
about the air pollution. Uh, they're
concerned about a dense populations in,
in a wild areas that,
uh, that was, uh, uh,
something that was less important
than freedom of access, uh, and, uh,
the right of the people to
make use of the land. So,
uh, some of the towns, uh,
already had a high
percentage of ownership, uh,
in state lands and this created a very
different kind of problem. So you know,
that,
uh,
towns get the majority of their income
from property taxes that get some state
subsidies for, for a variety of purposes,
including schools. But, uh, also, uh,
for, for transportation, uh, and
sometimes for a medical facilities.
Uh, but, uh, uh, a town
such as this town, uh, uh,
has the majority of its land
in public ownership already,
which means that it has a highly
restricted private tax base, uh,
so that the state of New York
pays payments in lieu of taxes.
Uh, but, uh,
these really are not comparable to the
kind of income that could be generated if
development were unregulated, if they
were allowed to build a more rapidly. Uh,
another example of a
conservation strategy, uh,
is demonstrated by this
case in the town of keen.
There is a long strip of land that's
privately owned by the US Sable Club that
extends back, uh, perhaps a six miles
in length and maybe a half, a mile wide.
Uh, and if I should have a photo here
that would show you that the, the sides,
uh,
of this lake go these lakes,
I'll go up quite dramatically
into the mountain side.
It's owned by a private club.
Uh,
and the private club decided that
they were going to self restrict their
development rights,
uh,
but that they were going to sell those
development rights to the state of New
York.
So the state of New York did not take
over complete ownership with the land.
But remember I said the property
rights might be thought of as a bundle.
They sold off the developable rights
to the landscape while maintaining the
underlying fee ownership, uh, so that, uh,
they were able to do this in a way that
reduced their tax burden. The tax burden,
uh, to this community, uh, was
substantial given the, uh, uh,
hundreds of acres of lands that they
own, a so that they were anxious to, uh,
go to the town and, and say,
look, you know, our property
value has been diminished.
We've given up our development rights, uh,
so that, uh, our taxpayers should, should,
uh,
be lowered.
There are a variety of different instances
where the Nature Conservancy, uh,
throughout the United States
is affected the strategy, uh,
and it's less expensive than the state
going in and buying up all rights to the
land. Uh, and it does
offer this benefit, uh,
for those that feel like they do not want
to see the area developed any further.
So, uh, in, in this debate
is in many debates, uh,
who are the key actors? Who
are the stakeholders that
are, that are common? Well,
there are interesting tensions between
conservationists and environmentalist, uh,
particularly in respect to the
intensity of use of public lands.
So that in the Adirondacks for example,
you,
you would have the Adirondack 40 sixers
that pride themselves in having climbed
all 46 peaks in excess of
4,000 feet in elevation.
And then you'd have the
environmentalist's, uh,
and they were often at odds
about what the right way to, uh,
manage public lands ought to be the
recreational user groups as there are
surrounding all public
lands in the United States.
And these might vary from cross country
skiers, uh, to, uh, snowmobilers,
uh, to downhill skiers, to timber
companies, to oil companies, uh,
to those that feel like they're a values
associated with those public lands that
they want access to, that they can make
a profit from a, there are tourists,
uh, corporations as well that always
surround these tracks of land. Uh, uh,
outfitters in the western part of the
United States, a horse pack, uh, uh,
uh, trip offers, uh, and, uh, uh,
another good example might be, uh,
uh, what happens with the tour boats
and the cruise ships up in Alaska.
Uh, they're also, uh, as I mentioned
earlier, a, they're commonly, uh,
serious conflicts between permanent
residents that are more anxious to see
additional development of the park and
the seasonal residents that are trying to
basically keep it as
undeveloped as possible.
And there are tensions among
government agencies. Uh,
the agency that existed before the
Adirondack Park Agency was the state's
department of Environmental Conservation
and it had authority before the,
the 1973 act to administer
private public lands.
So if you suddenly give that authority
and policy making responsibility to a
different organization,
you're going to have terrific resentment
on the part of the agency that formerly
had that, uh, authority,
just like local governments were
resentful about the state assumption of
authority. And then you have need of
American claims as well that, that, uh,
uh, uh, caused conflict in, in management,
both private and public lands and
led to litigation in the park. Uh,
what we're a time today and I'll pick
up a on public land issues and also
property rights questions with respect
to the fifth amendment on Thursday.
Thank you.